[Musique]
quelle est la différence entre un
méchant et un gentil qui fait de mauvaises choses
où est la frontière entre le pieux mensonge et
le mal absolu
Je veux que tu joues Robin Je veux que tu
leur arraches les yeux tu te souviens de
Johan dont je te parlais  Joe est un
génie, j'aimerais entendre votre
stratégie d'investissement, messieurs, que diriez-
vous de gagner de l'argent à la BBC, la seule
différence entre l'investissement à haut risque
et un stratagème de Ponzi, c'est ainsi que tout se termine,
cet accord vaut un quart de
milliard de dollars et  vos vies ne seront plus
jamais les mêmes,
les garçons milliardaires,
conduisez-vous une nouvelle voiture avant que cette voiture
ne vaille plus que mon appartement
[Musique] un
peu partout Joe détourne les
investisseurs pour payer les dépenses
vous pensez que les gens
deviennent vraiment riches en jouant selon les règles
où est l'argent il n'y a jamais eu d'
argent Ron avait un faux compte Ron Levin
m'a brûlé a dit que j'avais beaucoup d'argent
à beaucoup de gens je dois les
rembourser si les créateurs de la BBC  ev  Chaque document
sera sous le microscope de l'IRS
la SEC le FBI voudriez-vous lui
faire nous rendre notre argent parfois la
vérité est la meilleure
ligne fermez la bouche pour que personne ne puisse entendre et
crier où est le mal de rire
ne vous sentez pas coupable
vous